millions of americans are traveling this
week for thanksgiving but the holiday
rush got off to a chaotic start in
atlanta's main airport check this out
passengers scrambled for safety after a
gun accidentally discharged at the
security checkpoint on saturday now
thankfully no one was hurt errol barnett
is at the hartsfield-jackson atlanta
airport with the latest on this
investigation errol what can you tell us
about what happened
hey there nate good morning happy to
report things moving smoothly in atlanta
right now over the weekend though a much
different story at this checkpoint you
see behind me a passenger's bag was
flagged for secondary screening he then
reached in and the weapon discharged
accidentally folks around this location
scrambled the suspect ran and police
still have yet to catch up with him
panic travelers ran from the atlanta
airport saturday after gunfire at a
security checkpoint the passenger lunged
into his property grabbing a firearm
that was located inside which ultimately
discharged
the passenger then
fled the security checkpoint through an
adjacent exit lane luckily no one was
seriously injured but it did cause
delays plus many passengers had to
abandon their luggage with some being
evacuated to the tarmac police now
looking for the suspect 42 year old
kenny wells this security scare comes as
more than 4 million americans are
expected to fly for the thanksgiving
holiday more than an 80 percent increase
from last year andrew gross is spokesman
for aaa thanksgiving travel is back i've
heard it said that folks are looking at
this as our first vax giving because
more people ages five to 105 have at
least one dose of vaccination so people
are just feeling more confident
if you are driving instead of heading to
the airport this week expect congestion
and high gas prices the national average
of a gallon of gas is projected to be
its highest price in more than seven
years on thanksgiving day at three
dollars and 35 cents still more than 48
million americans are expected to travel
this holiday by car no matter how much
gasoline prices are people are still
going to take that trip they're just
going to figure out another way of
budgeting in for it
and the data supports that things are
already getting busy the tsa reports
there are more than 2 million daily air
passengers being screened in recent days
and today is also the deadline for tsa
staff to be vaccinated the agency does
not believe that will lead to any
disruptions this week we will check on
that and the best advice for travelers
is to show up at airports like this two
hours ahead of time if you're flying
domestically and if you're leaving the
country tony be safe and show up three
hours ahead of your flight
yeah be extra safe leave the firearm at
home even if you're from a legal state
errol thank you
very good advice